you've been there since 2013 right when
you were there were you aware that these
kinds of things was happening on PornHub
on PornHub I I mean these are things
that we're not really unfortunately able
to to talk about in too much detail
because these are about um ongoing
litigation so what I'm able to comment
on is is limited um because first of all
I'm Muslim I have a lot of kids is
follow me you know
and did you know that teaching a new
Muslim like me the entire Sal for the
next 50 years just cost £10 every time
they wake up
for you get the reward you could sponsor
salams for just 00 and help 10 new
Muslims learn how to pray Salah click
the button or the link and donate
[Music]
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends Subhan Allah I came across his
video of brother kabie I think that's
what his name is forgive me if I
pronounce it wrong
and I found it so profan and I was like
this is a this is a Muslim influencer
who I mean he doesn't really talk about
him practicing that we seing doesn't
practice but we seeing is just your
Muslim lay man mus yeah practicing
individual yes and I found what he said
so profound and I was like Subhan Allah
we're going to look at that and compare
what he said in his interview about
promoting alcohol or other Haram stuff
and how he refused and then compare
compare that to a Zionist Jew a a
Zionist Jew who is a rabbi who was a
defense criminal defense lawyer who
we're going to find out now who will
defend some really dodgy and Shady
people who decides to buy
PornHub okay so we're going to see the
stock difference in let's start off with
this reaction video of kab inshallah and
then we will come to the
following how do you work with Brands
and how does that how does what advice
do you have for brands that want to work
with you first of all I um I always when
they contact me I make sure that uh I'm
uh I'm promoting something that is not
going to uh uh promote uh I can promote
alcohol you know I can promote uh and I
I get a lot of offerss from alcohol but
I always say no because first of all I'm
Muslim you know and I don't want to
promote alcohol I have I have a lot of
kids follow me you know and I don't want
to the other people the kids starting to
drink and uh I always start to I always
uh uh choose the things that they're not
going
to make uh clean most clean possible you
know okay fantastic you guys just sort
that for yourself yeah and you can see
clearly he is saying no to alcohol let
alone something
worse which is Zena or prostitution or
whatever you want to call it yeah okay
uh people being exploited being abused
yes by the way cornhub we call that for
now cornhub was known for that of the
exploitation and not only that the
people being sexually trafficked it is
all boiling back to that in yeah so here
is a video Let's watch of these
co-workers being interviewed by Mr Pat
Patrick pet Davids um talking about the
harms ETA he we'll never talk about this
whenever you know call them out Zionist
Zionist rabbis owning places like this
inshah yeah okay so let's go uh this is
some interview and then we're going to
read an article that exposes them and
message look at this look at the message
of uh the brother kab Subhan Allah yeah
he will not even do alcohol so Subhan
Allah there is lessons that this
individual should learn from a lame
Muslim man Su and Visa go look go up Rob
let me see what it says is suan Visa the
best way to shut down PornHub B expert
said that targeting credit card
companies in a war against online six
traffic and have pushed too far can
cause unintended harms go a little lower
the story that I still want to get to
zoom in right okay second paragraph the
article United Firestorm protest and
litigation that deeply impacted a online
pornography IND this survivors and
anti-trafficking advocacy organization
many have ties to Christian right and
anti-p pornography efforts of the 1970s
and ' 80s gather more than 2 million
signatures on okay we just read that and
survivors of the anti-trafficking legal
claims of pornhub's parent company
mindgeek seeking millions of dollars in
Damages notably Serena fetes who was 13
years old when her ex-boyfriend uploaded
a sexually explicit video on PornHub
brought a novel trafficking lawsuit
against visa she alleged that the credit
card company who's provided mindgeek its
payment networks knowingly monetize
these images for profit so Alexander
you've been there since 2013 right when
you were there were you aware that these
kinds of things was happening on PornHub
on PornHub I I mean these are things
that we're not really unfortunately able
to to talk about in too much detail
because these are about um ongoing
litigation so what I'm able to comment
on is is limited um but there's a
there's a there's an active litigation
going on right now there's lawsuits that
relate back to how the site used to be
prior to the acquisition I'm asking you
because you've been there since 2013 so
I'm kind of glad you're here because how
much have you noticed culturally the
place changing because there is no way
you're working there and you don't know
this is out there right you would know
if you're working there that this is out
there I mean what I can tell you is that
I've seen a tremendous evolution in
PornHub since I've been there um I've
been there like you said since 2013 in
very different capacities like when I
started there I was working um in social
media and customer service so I can say
that I'm you know very proud to work for
a company where I was able to to grow in
the way that I have up to an executive
level today unbelievable I am proud to
work and I work my way up that's one
talking about not talking about the
sexual abuses the the the trafficking
and underrage girls Etc being exploited
all that kind of stuff no I'm work I'm
so proud to work for a company that I
work my way up as a sales manager to
where I'm high up now and you've got
this Solomon Friedman who is a Zionist
who was a criminal defense lawyer who
was defending very weird people who were
doing some really pedophilic stuff who
is now owning all of a sudden cornhub
and there he is and let's just read this
article end on this forget this guy yeah
let's end this woman prophetic terrible
individuals yeah okay let's read this
this is a a article about them a rabbi
is overseeing cornhub that's actually
not so weird let's read here you go this
is written by my fox it's really not as
shocking as it sounds that Rabbi has
become one of the top officials running
cornhub the free interet
pornography uh be off after all the
Investments Group that bought corn up is
called ethical Capital partners and
Solomon Freedman the rabbi in question
and the investment companies co-founder
and chief compliance officer is trying
to Cle up the internet a thank you Rabbi
you're going to come and clean it up for
us for all the Gentiles for the yes that
you do not care about as Muslims we are
told to enjoy good with evil it's not we
don't we Muslims don't say all right
protect the Muslims from alcohol and
drug and you know pornography and all
that kind of stuff but let the
disbelievers just they no no no no no no
we don't have that in our religion we
say this illness affects everybody and
we should protect them all see the
difference that's what kab was doing and
look at this Rabbi Zionist Rabbi okay
and look what he's doing he's come to
clean up he's the police oh thank you
Rabbi okay more people might be confused
by the idea of a religious leader being
involved with a pornography company
after all isn't it just a sin aren't
Rabbi supposed to be kind of a moral
police but Judaism is actually pretty
sex positive most Jewish text about sex
focus on understanding and regulating
the ACT not warning people of it's
dangerous the T has passages introducing
husbands to have regular sex with their
wives emphasizing the importance of
pleasure and encouraging ex uh
experimentation um and this is something
really weird I don't know what it meant
there's even a tale of a student being
hiding under his rabbi's bed when where
his teacher has sex with his wife and
when the student is caught he argues
that everything in the Torah was just
trying to learn I have no idea what he
talking about but let's get this right
of course Jud talks about about sex
nobody said nothing about that yes we're
not talking about that we're talking
about Zionist who taking this out of
context or whatever is for that matter
because now having intimacy with your
wife is not the same of having a a a a
website that has 13 million viewers per
day who is watching adultery happen do
you see it a Muslim is not allowed to
own any kind of pornography website for
that matter why because they don't
believe in the other they can do it let
them be ruined let them destroy them and
that's one of the reasons why uh there's
conspiracy and all the kind of stuff
from the far right saying that these
zionists who were coming and trying to
destroy the nuclear family of the white
man because they they trying to control
the all that kind of stuff let's carry
on in yeah uh okay and it says mind you
fre Freedom was never a practice in
Rabbi he grew up in an orthodox family
in Canada and was ordained in Jerusalem
but then he became a criminal defense
lawyer making a name for himself by
defending extremely sketchy characters
accused of such offenses as sexual abuse
possession of child pornography and
drunk driving so really for
so really fredman's Rabbi Co plits are
just fed for a clicky headline like the
one published by the time his actual
career is pretty uh obvious fit for the
yeah okay trying to defend him okay yeah
okay the problem with horab is it isn't
just necessary the fact that it provides
porn thought uh though of course plenty
of people object that to but porn has
existed for thousands of years blood
blood blood blood blah forget all that
yeah okay it says Solomon fredman since
Solomon and got involved with the pornup
videos have been circulating on X and
Reddit accusing him of encouraging
pedophilia thanks to his criminal
defense work others list him alongside
other Jews who have been involved with
pornography or simply with dating abs
and such as Tinder as proof of a Jewish
conspiracy to the Jew to destroy the
white nuclear family fredman told the
Washington Post that this that his
children has been subjected to horrific
anti-Semitism since he invested in pup
now of course and Sen is wrong 100%
nobody can justify that you know and
this is this is sickening but I think
your children will more sick Solomon
frean would you allow your children your
children your Zionist Jewish children to
appear on that uh uh no you'll never
you'll never and this is exactly what
we're talking about so brothers and
sisters I just want to end on this note
that as Muslims we are told to want good
the prophet Muhammad said move an
harmful object from the road the lowest
form of faith is moving a harmful object
from the road Subhan Allah we are there
to K tell for everybody and care about
everyone being be Muslim or non Muslim
but you do not see that with the
zionists you do not see with them they
do not care about the goyam the Gentile
you they are destroying your youth your
generation your woman your men the
Zionist yes they are and you got the far
right who are backing and defending them
cuz they don't care about that they
don't see these things the epin Islands
how he had a connection to mad you don't
hear about that so alhamdulillah may
Allah bless and preserve brother kab for
being principled a true Muslim who does
not promote any of these vile things
that destroy destroy Society and that is
what a real Muslim does in and that's
what Islam teaches and that is the
reason why Islam is the only religion
that's been attacked Left Right Center
you know why CU we want goodness for
everybody I will leave you on that
inshah brother and sisters may Allah
bless cab inshah and that's itam alum